good afternoon thank you so much for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casa as we begin with that
breaking story a man is shot and killed
by police in the northeast valiant
intersection blocked off for most of the
day as the investigation continues let's
check in with the i-team's vanessa
murphy she's live now near charleston
and sloan vanessa
one man is dead after police say he
pointed his weapon at officers police
tell us this started around nine this
morning around lake mead and jones it
started with a kidnapping and then ended
here with that deadly shooting
captain carlos hank says an armed
suspect kidnapped an ex-girlfriend metro
officers tracked them down near
charleston and sloan according to hank
officers tried to de-escalate the
situation the suspect pointed his weapon
at officers they opened fire the suspect
pronounced dead at the scene the woman
is safe and no officers are hurt this
northeast valley intersection blocked
off as a crime scene for most of tuesday
with a heavy police presence including
csi the mobile command unit and the
police union per department policy metro
is expected to release more information
later this week
and back out here live you can see again
this is the intersection by charleston
and sloan you see there is still a
police presence that's blocked off over
here that continues we have the crime
scene tape here that continues past this
shopping mall you have albertsons over
here again police still investigating as
they try to piece together what happened
reporting live in the northeast valley
vanessa murphy live local now